jay has the number one show on
television
and like he said like in in letterman's
days that block of jay leno followed by
conan o'brien is probably the most
lucrative two hours of television in
existence and when that started don
ohmeyer after 13 weeks wanted to get rid
of conan and i said no i think he's
funny and i said tell you what i will
promote conan every night i'll at the
end of my show i'll say stay tuned for
conan he's got uh you know so elton john
whatever yeah because he had a rough
start yeah yeah so and and that worked
fine and that worked great
so listen to this and he knew too
i know the story i know the ins i meant
nbc okay
so he's kicking ass this is the most
lucrative
you know two hours of television there
is and ultimately television is just um
a
factory right right okay
not only is it lucrative this guy
and i'm pointing again at jay leno has
masterminded
i mean i i always found this fascinating
when you did the tonight show not only
uh you know is he is it doing well it's
not doing well by accident you watch the
ratings you know
how to book it you know where the
ratings go down he was the one person
that would support me when i had nothing
and i was doing hidden howies you know i
was doing these hidden camera pieces and
he put me on but i would hand in
uh hidden camera things he would look at
it and he goes i can't i can't
sometimes this will not play well this
one would say to him howie can we lose
the cockadoodoo bit
i mean that was really what it was
because i loved her but i could just see
from our audience and i would see from
fred to carnival who was kind of snobby
that
that was not johnny's it was still
johnny's sensibility right at that point
you know right so i would say and how he
did he would say okay i'll take out the
doo doo cocka thing and then and then it
would kill it but here's but the point
that i'm making is you weren't on a show
that was number one you were on a show
that you
manipulated to be number one you worked
that show you weren't just on that show
that was the jay leno show right right
so
and nbc and people who watch should be
aware of that that is not by accident
he also supported the show that went
after him and the network
by promoting and creating that
slot after him to be number one
when
that came when conan's contract
came up to
fruition
um everybody because that's where they
want to make money cbs fox abc is you
know waiting to maybe poach him right
they go to uh to uh conan's people gavin
pallone they go to gavin and they say we
want to re-up the contract
he goes well
the only way you can re-up it is we need
a tonight show
he goes well
jay's doing the tonight show and it's
number one he goes i don't care we need
the tonight show
they go well jay's got another five
years on his contract
right am i if i'm incorrect jay's got
another five years on his content they
go i don't care
then we don't know what's happening in
five years
they risk versus reward they say well
we're not going to lose this hour
to
fox or abc
okay we'll say in five years and then if
something happens maybe
in their minds we'll renegotiate we'll
say you get the tonight show in five
years they sign that gavin says i want
it announced now
right right right am i correct yeah yeah
yeah i'm correct yeah i know i'm correct
yeah yeah so they call you
one of my friends called you
and said
you have to announce
your retirement you didn't announce a
return you don't want to retir you look
at how busy you are now here's my thing
at the time i know
if you don't do that you die of a
thousand paper cuts
why
because
little stories will drop about
you being
disruptive or not doing that you know so
i said
you know it to me it's like when i would
date women if they don't want to go out
with me i'm not going to beg you
if you don't see him anymore fine fine
and that's why i said to nbc i said you
want me out of here in five years really
okay fine so okay but let's be clear you
don't want to retire no i don't want to
retire but i said
but i know if you
look when you make the kind of money you
make in tv to the average person you
have no problems at all and your
problems pale in comparison to theirs so
don't even bring them up so i said okay
so go the five years see the real
uh thing that threw this was craig
ferguson because i was number one
conan was number one all right the deal
was made lana you're leaving in five
years
all right so i said okay
well slow down okay slow down
i want to make it really clear
you did not retire
legitimately you did not say you did not
announce a legitimate retirement where
you said i've had enough in five years
well i think that's the worst i think i
said yeah they wanted me to say i was
saying all right that's fine okay if
that's what they want that's what they
want not what you wanted is my point no
right which i
i would have a hard time
telling the world
this is what i've decided to do you're
right about why but you're amazing to me
that here's what happens is then the
whole machine
remember i had no agent i had no manager
no never had okay uh so then i know your
lawyer then the whole neighborhood pr
thing starts
with the attacks ratings start to drop
for leno you know whatever whatever they
can come up with they do so so i would
have done i would have hired an agent or
a manager or a a publicist you know if i
have to convince you to love me
i'm not going to do that
you know you like what i'm doing you
know i never once asked for a raise they
just gave them to me i said okay
no i know that the difference between
like letterman used to he took uh you
know worldwide pants which was the
production company and he used to
produce
you know all these other shows that he
only owned raymond yeah he owned all
these other he made a fortune probably
made more from that than he made from
the from the late night show i came to
you a couple times i said i got an idea
i want to produce something under big
dog big dog production yeah yeah which
you're pretty
i just do the tonight show and i do my
stand up come
i you can't know how much i respected
you for just you are who you are and you
do what you do well i mean that's what
it is see the thing
the story was
craig ferguson came along and then
suddenly he was beating conan
and the network went oh
what's this all about
you know because his ratings are so good
he won a peabody award he wants some
emmys
and then it was like did we make a
mistake i said
guys i'm here and then they came to me
and they said uh
look the thing with conan is a done deal
you know next year whenever well let me
let me
because i know my friend i want to take
you through like how you thought of this
okay so not only the you just cut him
off to take him through how he thought
of that okay no go ahead
go ahead i'll let you finish no go ahead
okay you talk and then on well
no no welcome to my life my whole
childhood he cut me off to tell me what
i was thinking
uh i i don't know where i was going now
well good i'm a good interviewer
no but here's so so you announced this
retirement against your will
he's going down i just want to say i
just want people to know everything and
i want to get this out this is stuff
that's been laying on my chest
apparently it's not on yours
[Laughter]
um
they realized really quickly
that if you announced your retirement
that abc cbs and fox
you're there for the poaching right
right
so right away they say to you as soon as
they realize that
they go jay
you can don't go to another network
we're gonna make your show the same show
in prime time
right which i knew wouldn't work so the
deal i made was
if you pay my staff
for two years regardless of what happens
i'll do it because i think they were
keeping me
in case conan didn't work out i think
they were keeping you because they
didn't want you to go some other place
yeah then
management gavin pallone
calls the network
and says
all right so we have the tonight show at
11 30.
you just gave jay
the 10 p.m show
i think you're [ __ ] us because
i'll just tell you as my myself if i
have something to promote or i want to
go on something
i'm going to go on prime time first you
know there is this war of booking right
right where do you go first you go to
jay first right you go to the once you
go to jay then you can't go to you know
if you go to fallon you can't go to
right
to so so then he goes you're [ __ ] us
so now they call you and you've said i'm
keeping my staff which is you were
always amazing to your staff and anybody
who's worked for you has the same thing
to say you know you were there for them
you always supported them and then they
say to you jay we said you can do your
show at 10 o'clock
no
no you can't do the same show you can't
have guests
we'll build you a race track
right yeah well we could have some
guests but they wanted the monologue at
the end of the show to lead into the new
yeah it just didn't work right
anything just to keep you there right
right
[Music]
you